imagine you look at the world it looks a
little bit more in certain that it did
six months ago this was the main thrust
of your speech why we see the baseline
as a slightly lower but we also see what
we call downside risks a bit higher on
the horizon and we don't see much by way
of upside so we believe that these three
key risks that are China change of
business model and as a result lower
growth the lower commodity price for
longer and the tightening of financials
as a result of new monetary policies
that has just begun and more probably
will come out to as the three key
factors that's on the economic front but
then on the top of it we see also some
very concerning geopolitical threats
that have an economic impact on many
countries around the world and then we
have of course guess folding both is
braggs it is that in your top three
risks for this year well it's it's
clearly part of the uncertainty that we
have at the moment particularly in the
European Union and concerning the
financial sector as well because of the
size of the financial sector that London
represents you talked about China and
we're concerned about the debt load
there we're concerned that actually
despite all of the central bank action
we're still in this no growth or very
low growth economic rut are we sewing
the seeds for another recession or with
a pair of shine I wouldn't say that
china is no growth you know we forecast
China 6.5 percent it's really something
to write home of us if we add more more
of those countries countries with but we
see the Chinese authorities as being
determined to tackle some of the
fragilities of the system and you know
when all leaders come out to reinforce
the fact that they will restructure the
state-owned enterprises which are
clearly one drag on growth particularly
in that change of business models you
don't need as much i own you don't need
as much construction you don't need as
much of the heavy-duty manufacturing
a work that has had been done for
decades in China so that is a
restructuring which will imply a lot of
hard work a lot of you know manpower
being retrained hopefully and it implies
a lot of balance sheet revision that
will have an impact in in the longer
term but in a way the fact that China
can produce those pillows around the
world it's a bit of a badge of honor of
being part and a critical part of the
globalization of the economy you don't
worry about recession though even if all
the the concerning news were to come
true either on the geopolitics front or
the political front you know what what
what we fear is this sort of very new
mediocre that I have warned about last
year which would mean you know weak
growth no no no new jobs no high
inflation still high debt all those
things that should be low in that are
high you know continuing that trend so
we call for policy actions and we call
for what I have named the three-pronged
approach which combines structural
measures fiscal policies and monetary
policy so the three together not just
one up there the other we're seeing a
lot of monetary policies at the moment
but we need the three and we need it
fast